[Music]
in dangerous boobs news
submitted by Joe Molly and janitor oh
you King up the mess how's the path
pretty good because they have to clean
up a lot of dead body parts I see a
woman is suing a restaurant alleging she
was hurt by a drag queens breasts like
their titties fell on the floor this
woman from Florida is suing a restaurant
for 1.5 million dollars issues together
Florida come on listen to look at me
that's a lot of money [ __ ] crazy
is this a big restaurant I don't know
how big this restaurant is but they're
known for having these drag queen shows
in the restaurant is it illegal to
assassinate people that try to sue you
no yes really no I've done horrible no
cuz if you're gonna assassinate them
you're gonna do it under the radar
anyway so it's legal it's not illegal
until you get caught double jeopardy
it's chill if it's double jeopardy still
has to go to trial get away with it no
Ana and then it is you it if they catch
me double jeopardy don't look at me like
that good well it's gonna happen all
right so this restaurant called
Hamburger Mary's in Tampa how you gonna
[ __ ] sue a place called Hamburger
Mary's yeah they're gonna hurt me I'm
gonna hurt them back but it sounds like
the most loving places they know that's
like suing grandma's cookies I've heard
of Hamburger Mary's you have it sounds
like famous or something is it I don't
know how famous it makes my mouth water
those woman named nailed in Memphis she
sounds like she's up to no her head she
sounds like she would go to a hamburger
Barry's yeah so she was celebrating a
friend's birthday she said she had never
been to our restaurant before so you
know what to expect
wait she's never been to a restaurant to
that restaurant easy guys everyone's
ready to jump yeah no I was just trying
to be as crispy
no you're fine yeah you're crispy you're
fine I mean her name is Nell didn't yeah
it just seems like a person with that
name it is believable that they've never
been to a restaurant before has an Amish
flared and then they live in
the middle they live in buckle shoe town
yeah yeah I've been Amish name sure
that's what this anonymous dress all the
buckle shoes you have buckle shoe shoes
all right so she went to that restaurant
celebrate your friend's birthday she was
saying that she was eating her dinner
when all of a sudden at 8:45 p.m. the
music started and the entire crowd
started to clap a person on the
microphone announced that the drag queen
show was about to begin and then that's
when came here for hamburgers not for
the Jack Queen's like that no it's when
a performer named Amanda jihad came over
to her table and but then Nelda and just
ignored her but then later on the dancer
came back and then grabbed her head and
wiggled her breasts against the
plaintiffs face and had eight times they
counted that counted one two three four
five six seven eight that's pretty [ __ ]
what are the four five six seven eight I
know I was trying to deliver buzzes
seven eight oh that's a good rhythm yes
she remembered everybody says oh I'm a
dancer I'm glad our crack team is on the
case awesome that was the evidence she
later complained to the manager
later that night complained she filed
like an incident report saying that she
was experiencing excruciating pain and
that she had a headache she'd go
whiplash yeah and then she said that she
went to the ER to be treated for
excruciating cervical pain and
uncontrollable yeah yeah that's what I
was thinking about circles whatever it's
cervical is like it's the neck of your
head and the neck oh then they [ __ ] up
how are you gonna name two body parts
the same name thank you you know that's
like saying you know your penis no your
wrist you [ __ ] idiot it's like no
your penis wrist the wrist bone is
called a penis bone okay Jesus
grabbed my piece oh my god all the kids
little boys think he grabbed my penis
really hard well now you guys know that
part of the neck is called a circle I
did test that listen now she's saying
that she's suing for that amount that I
told you 1.5 million dollars in seeking
medical costs and expenses for the past
present in the future
all no looting the pain and suffering
she's physically and mentally endure are
you mocking this person who does who got
abused by breasts yes and she had to
bring the [ __ ] ghost of Christmas
past president future that his mother
[ __ ] is this sound so ridiculous like
lady heaven and there was like carpe
diem or some [ __ ] is she related to the
American Idol kid with the Katy Perry
kid yeah exactly cuz that's what it
sounds like exactly ungrateful yeah
ungrateful she also alleged that the
restaurant failed to inform customers of
any possible dangers while eating
dangers at a tea to the face it's not
dangerous this person can't wait to sue
ya just waiting for it she's probably
gonna try to sue me for mocking her
[ __ ] overdramatic as [ __ ]
that want to blow up a situation and
take advantage of it
yeah I bet you in her head she's right
America she's probably planning before
this she was probably planning on suing
them because when she took a bite of the
burger it explored her taste buds it was
so [ __ ] good
and then she was like oh I got hit in
the face with tits that's way better
than my first idea like she's one of
those people who can't wait to sue for
anything like the bathroom sink it
turned on and it is too [ __ ] hot yeah
I feel like people just look for lawful
lawsuits that are like this to just scam
it all day long like to McDonald's
coffee thing man mm-hmm
well actually that really burned the
[ __ ] out of her really it was like the
dickens did it really it was like oh
there's just a little hot no she got
like birds and there's pictures and then
like it was a pretty big deal so when I
when I investigated that case I was like
case closed
that shit's real like an argument with
Mickey I'm gonna say I don't really
agree I think that my point is better
and then I'm just gonna slowly back away
even though I know in my head I'm wrong
that's the best way to do it thank you I
think so there are a lot of cases like
that because there's like people out
there that are purposely trying to look
for car accidents yes or they feel those
the best
the Russian ones the Russian wants it go
themselves on cars and [ __ ] I love that
didn't there on the - can they get up
like oh the funniest one that I saw
recently was I could do it on a
motorcycle he goes in front and he stops
she stops what's this guy doing and he
starts walking his motorcycle backwards
and then hit and then he falls right and
then he goes lady what are you doing
then he has a friend to corroborate it
right comes over she goes I saw you hit
him she goes [ __ ] camera then they go
they start trying to run it but he runs
the wrong direction and so he has to go
back this way again sometime Jesus oh my
god I love that [ __ ] people who make
money off of scammin see that's why they
should make it legal to assassinate
people that want to sue you and that
should be totally fine because it's like
hey they're trying to [ __ ] you so isn't
it okay to get rid of these people but
if you want to see someone I'm not gonna
try to sue so it has to be has a lot of
guns yeah it has to be like suing
someone for the sake of stealing from
them like you you're not suing because
it's like Oh unfair you know mean like
like people be like hey man you [ __ ]
crashed into me and my neck is broken
but it's legit
that's a fine suit yeah like 1.5 million
40d slap that's not sue for fairness
yeah I just looked at Burger Mary's and
you're right it's actually a chain yeah
like a Red Robin or something can I look
at this hamburger Mary I want to see
what the hamburgers look like I want to
see what the store looks oh it's even
got a lady with tits on the [ __ ]
thing yeah
as their branding yeah but it's a drag
queen hamburger place this is their logo
oh so it's a drag queen hamburger oh
it's a burger with the knife in it that
means those burgers are delicious how
you know the difference yeah like that I
like yeah I'm all about presentation big
and juicy burgers man
yummy a Google actual hamburger from
there no I probably don't work because
if I see a drag queen I lost my appetite
what I love a drag queen oh dude drag
queens shits the best shut the hell up
you were the one that said the Thai
women with dick that's not a drag queen
that's a hot ass girl with a dick okay
that's different very very different you
know why it's because the movie to Wong
foo
that's a very bad depiction I know but
that have you seen Hedwig
that's what ingrained what a drag queen
and in Hollywood there's a lot of really
buff like guys have you seen RuPaul's
Drag Race
yes yeah it they are gorgeous I don't
know about that Hedwig and the Angry
Inch is one a legit one of the best I
think probably movie slash musicals ever
RuPaul's Drag Race they're gorgeous in
the drag queen type of world yeah but
that's just a as just they still look
like men though uh-uh
I'll show you one one week I saw
RuPaul's I've seen it they still look
like men RuPaul looks like a dude for an
establishment like that that was delish
I don't think I would lose my appetite
oh my eater I need that guacamole other
hamburger yeah blue cheese dip blue
cheese Wow I'm down with that
yeah so it's drag queens on roller
skates yeah it's like LGBT as tight
that's really cool it's yeah I've heard
of it yeah I take it back those burgers
are so good nothing could like I could
have a kid vomit next to me while I'm
eating that [ __ ] it don't matter
yeah it's like I'm like probably the
most worse like Yelp reviewer cuz I
literally don't care about anything else
but for me too so they'll come in and
they'll spit in my spit in my face
whatever call me a [ __ ] fat ass but
as long as the food's good I'll still
come because side of my food and if it
tastes good I don't care I [ __ ] see a
cockroach running across the restaurant
while I'm eating and I'm like do dishes
Bob you know what I've been here I went
to a friend's birthday party now
remember in Florida or in Hollywood
oh there's one in Hollywood all right
there is one Hollywood yeah
I haven't been all we need to go there
then yeah we gotta go there what do you
do right a drag queen there do drag
queens are the best how you guys have
you guys been to a drag queen thing at
all and that was the one they're [ __ ]
fun man
there's fun P I'm just joking grey
people really
[Music]